alors annette messager était la
spécialiste
du bricolage d'après photos ces centres
est ce que tu appelles ma cuisine
c'est quoi la recette
pas dans celle là pas de recette je
tenais à dire la recette on commence par
faire des fautes au départ mais tout le
monde fait des photos ouais c'est les
photos de pippa
deschamps dany je connais
je crois que la photo c'est justement le
dernier art populaire et tout le monde
équilibre sans pensée qui fait de la cie
la beauté de la photo dans ses photos tu
les fais après tu les tifs les à la mort
fausse voulait lasserre filer des coups
tupin par dessus sur photographies
l'ensemble ces savants oui moi je vais
l'apprendre ce que tu fais mais c'est à
dire que en ce moment je fais des gros
plans de jean damy
veille les marines et
steira et puis sur la planche contact
encore je sélectionne jurait a grandi
j'ai vraiment l'impression que me les
approprier gelé
les développe il les a grandi au labo
chez moi et je les souvent je les isole
de noir c'est à dire qu'une
un oeil et noir autres courts très
fragmenté enfin les photos finalement
sur les choses que tu photographies qui
sont très sains finissent par acquérir
un pouvoir magique en quelque forme
j'aime beaucoup les ex bottle cas dans
les églises dans les églises espagnoles
italiennes mexicaine qui sont des
fragments de corps comme ça et où si on
a eu une maladie on a eu mal à l'épaule
au bord et c'est qu'on est guéri on
donne on offre à l'église une partie
comme ça du corps entier ou bien en
métal argenté et les églises souvent et
hélène sont constellés mais vraiment
bien d'agglomération de morceaux de
corps comme ça qui se superposent les
uns les autres et ces fragments de corps
qui évoque la maladie et la guérison
moi je voulais faire ça va être une
sorte de maladie amoureuse je pense que
la maladie d'amour et la maladie tous
ses très proches
d'ailleurs quand on est plus amoureux on
dit qu'on est guéri saori charlevoix et
bien-être artistes qu'il faut se
préserver tout ça parce qu'on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment du marché de l'art
et ce sera mon avis ça va tuer
complètement
on provoque la recette formidable en ce
moment la peinture magique dans toutes
les têtes mais l'artiste investissent
dans l'orne et moi je crois que les tee
shirts personnes et les entraîneurs jeu
très dangereux j'ai dit allez les
cantons commencé qu'on pense à ça
pauline des artistes en quoi tu penses
qui remet en valeur une certaine
cette approche de la réalité c'est
sympathique ses bras la petite chose
pendant un petit point et louis l'école
danton coins du monde comme ça ferait
bien quand même si envié de ligne
définition de son toit soasta coiffe
mais j'espère échapper à tout est fini
ce matin épitaphe alors c'est gai comme
question fatalement mon épitaphe toi qui
aime bien les ex voto les églises comme
ça aussi une pierre avec toi mais je
trouve que annette messager c'est un
très beau nom parce que si tu as
c'est justement message est un 2 2
voilà là mais qu'il s'agit
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu